[Music]
the top five in out the day has finally
arrived your interview with ET no I'm
kidding ah queer eyes available now on
Netflix I mean you guys must be so
excited with how do you feel now that
it's out to the world relieved we've
kept the secret allowed to talk about
and now we've just been waiting for it
to get released like the internet guess
what I'm in also it's Netflix so like
they release all the episodes at once
you really had to wait it's been it's
been amazing because all day long we
have been getting messages from around
the world from people watching the
episodes right now they're like we're on
Episode five we're on episode ten time
and they are just all saying we love it
we are crying I'm laughing and so it's
this immediate response because of
social media because of Netflix that
we've never had before yeah well I mean
I watched the first episode so many
fills I anticipate a lot of people are
gonna be reaching out to you guys after
they watched it was amazing but people
keep messing saying I'm crying I'm
crying I'm crying I love that feeling
my favorite moment though I think that
was watching us dubbed in Italian it's a
show for literally everybody was like
I try to channel my inner Donatella
Versace I understand I also love the
chemistry between you guys
did any of you know each other before oh
that's the first day of casting that is
drama found a video of us on the first
day of casting where literally us three
were already sitting next to each other
he was covered up in tans jacket you see
them in the background we knew it's like
our one-year anniversary so you guys
like besties now I would say like
brothers because you know I didn't grow
up with brothers and so if this has been
a learning curve for me of like what
it's like to have brothers but it's
amazing because you have people you can
lean on you can turn to for support
you can laugh with and it's just a
really good time to spend this many
months helping people with people you
love yeah and like when you're doing a
makeover show in Atlanta in the dead of
summer when you're keeping like one
Hurston you know like trying to make one
person look great in enamel so you know
we've all been through the trauma of
keeping five grown men and another man
from not looking like we're sweating
today yeah so that is a trauma bond
right there you guys were in the
trenches exactly
so the original queer premiered in 2003
where were you what were you doing in
2003 I was walking through my sister's
were watching the show and I watched it
in secret as I was walking through the
living room and they were like getting
the tips cuz I felt sort of like Shay me
and weird about it and I was a junior in
high school I was just in high school
and I was very actually junior I was a
sophomore I just graduated early so I
forgot he's gone Wow but that's show I
mean it was so important for me like
being on a river like in the middle of
America to like see that
I was my mom but yeah it was really
pretty
it's definitely big shoes to step into
because like anytime you know you're
coming back into something and this was
such a beloved show and I think all of
us you know it when you speak on like
the relief part it's like just such big
shoes to fill in and the original fad
have been so gracious and me and Carson
we're just chatting last night a little
bit on Instagram and it's just really
nice to have them be open and have these
shoes beat I think I think we were in
them yeah yeah it's big but like were
standing in their shoes
yeah different shoes and they're
gorgeous are both greets at a booth yeah
I say we want loafers I say we walk the
path of the original five okay but in
our own shoes yeah which is pretty
amazing because no one is going to look
at the fat five original fat five and
then look at us and say oh they're
trying to make him this person try to
make him this person we are uni if we
are individual so we all bring something
new and fresh and I think that's why
this is gonna resonate with people
around the world in such an amazing way
yes world spokeswoman yeah just a little
bit more because obviously the fifteen
years ago I mean a lot has changed since
then why was now the perfect time to
bring queer I back the thing is I think
the reason it's important to come back
is when you have a Republican
administration in the White House it's
really important that we Ryan obviously
Greg one was 2003 to 7 which was there
in the waning years of Bush so now in
the waxing years of Trump we need to
like I think waxing up getting bigger
yeah you totally just need to have like
we need to have you know some queer
visibility I'm telling what's important
about that is is you know we're in such
a divided place right now people seem
like they're not talking anymore
everyone is on this side and on this
side and what queer eye on what we're
doing as a Fab five is we're trying to
go into these places in the south where
people are dividing and saying you know
what we're more alike than we are
different
so let's come together and work it out
and be fabulous together we know that
sorry we know the things that make us
different so what we're trying to do is
find the things that make us the same
yeah but we kind of we need a feel-good
show my boyfriend watched the episodes
and he was saying he's like it's a type
of show that I can watch after a whole
long day at the office where I'm like
super tired and wiped out I can just go
home and feel like I'm getting a warm
hug yeah what it is absolutely it's a
British Bake Off which is now
and what's crazy is like that importance
right the impact and culture something
you guys are way more aware of going
into this series than they original work
right and so the you state an in the
promo that struck a chord with me was
the original was about tolerance this
one's about acceptance
how do you guys address that in this
show how do you fight for it do you know
we fight just being ourselves so we talk
about everything in our lives yes on the
show and when you watch the original
show they were doing these amazing
makeovers and it was so much fun but you
didn't really learn a lot about the rich
the original fat five I don't think that
it was a right forum the right platform
to be able to say I've got a boyfriend
I've got a kid like it's just not
appropriate Lisbon or a husband and this
is 2018 we should be able to talk about
every facet of our lives yeah we
represent every man we represent
different community different cultures
different religions so I think that's
why we're saying we're fighting for
tolerance we're fighting for acceptance
sorry this is the time to accept us as
your brothers your kin your father's
your brothers whatever changing culture
one makeover at a time it is the
makeover show which is fun you know
we're improving lives that changed
exactly like you know they're our
neighbors ready for this now I know oh
they should be right we're all right so
talk to me about the makeovers I mean do
we still get that trepidation from those
men oh yeah what's the biggest challenge
for them for my part of a makeover
wasn't with with an episode where we had
to say goodbye to a topknot and and say
hello to a new version of a beard he was
really nervous and so that was like I've
never seen someone when I washed their
hair their legs just her stick straight
so that one was hard what about you know
I think that their biggest fear is they
think that we're gonna come in there and
just pick them apart like everything
that's wrong with them and just put it
out there for the world to see but we're
really coming and looking for everything
that's great about them and finally
letting them see it because that's the
biggest I think that their biggest
hurdle in their lives was seeing what
everyone else sees about them yeah for
me I think a lot of it was these men I
really kind of go take these better like
emotional journey I like try to figure
out what the beer things
these are this holding them back and a
lot of times men are taught you got to
hold that in yeah you can't talk about
your feelings you can't express what's
going on in your life you can't be
curious about what's happening in your
wives lives here you know without
seeming weak and so for me they were
nervous of like why I don't want to be
too emotional I don't want to be too
emotional I was like let it go because
some of these guys eat to basically
survive like we have Cory for example
you're so really good friends but this
is someone who is terrified of his own
kitchen he's never prepared a meal for
his own family and although he didn't
have a really strong interest in cooking
per se but when we gave him a reason to
do it to connect with his daughters and
his wife like that served as an impetus
to sort of get his ass his butt sorry no
back in the kitchen and just just to
start doing that again isn't it crazy
how there's an emotional attachment to
everything you guys are addressing for
that explore that to our field trips as
well where we sort of you know it wasn't
as delineated and sort of as strict as
it was I think that's the beauty of it
I'm glad you just said that we're
Renaissance man each of us could
actually do what the other one does you
know there we're experts in our field
[Laughter]
we're all Renaissance men and we
actually do a really good job alive of
being able to support each other in each
other's categories and I think that's
what's beauty of it is that I tan could
you know I could talk about passion with
ten I could talk about food with him he
could talk about culture all the time
you know we all mesh well and so you see
that in the show it's not just that we
match well we we match want to work
together to make sure we're doing the
best for this hero with you guys and we
want the best no one of us doesn't know
an area to help them win we work
together we band together and that's why
I think it works so well you guys pair
up to production for also not heavily
producing and giving us the freedom to
have that discussion
sometimes we thought we had a plot we
thought we had this whole trajectory for
the course of the hero and then we'd get
together and realize that you know what
this person's needs are different and it
doesn't work or sometimes you see a
little clip of their toes and you didn't
have a chance to do a pedicure
they're like great way of sharing that
one of the other big differences I think
between the original and how we're
getting to help them
the original was mostly New York City
yeah usually just either single guys
bachelors in apartments in New York
we're getting to help families you know
like if you look at the quarry episode
we went to the quarry episode thinking
we were helping this one cop who loved
to go to NASCAR who had parties in his
basement and I went in thinking okay I'm
gonna maybe give him a better party
basement yeah but then we got there and
we realized he was spending a little too
much time in the heart yeah and he
needed to be upstairs with his wife and
daughters and so I decided last second
to redo the upstairs of his house
instead of the downstairs and we all
taught him you know he taught him how to
do the girls how to relate to his
children and he thought he might address
how not just for his self but for his
wife and it was really pretty because we
got to help the entire family not just
one guy so talk about the key key you
guys had with the original Fab Four one
of them was missing right to cut out
well what advice did they guys give you
about embarking on this journey Carson
said more important than anything
remember to have fun and just to sort of
stay in a moment which is easier said
than done I'm realizing now because it
we're so obsessed like what's the next
thing it's like last night on Instagram
I used to play I was like why I was like
I'm nervous and he would like on my
Stern he's like well why are you nervous
like although work is over it's like cuz
you created some beautifully big shoes
and stuff and just I think we would be I
think we would be like vegetables like
we weren't you know if we weren't a
little nervy
you